2021 was a banner year for science fiction
movies, filled to the brim with Kaiju showdowns,
time-loop extravaganzas, and classic franchise
fare. Here's the question, though: just how
many of these excellent sci-fi movies have
you seen?
Little Fish is a movie that blends romance
and drama with the world of science fiction.
Released in theaters and on streaming services
in February 2021, director Chad Hartigan's
movie is set in Seattle in the near-future,
in the midst of an epidemic of an Alzheimer's-like
illness known as NIA. Olivia Cooke and Jack
O'Connell star as Emma and Jude, a couple
struggling with the effect of NIA on their
relationship and society. Little Fish was
filmed before COVID-19 and was due to be shown
at the canceled 2020 Tribeca Film Festival.
This means that its underlying premise is
coincidental — but incredibly timely, too.
Entertainment Weekly's Mary Sollosi writes
that, despite the subject matter, Little Fish
resonates mostly as a love story. She also
praises the performances from Cooke and O'Connell,
writing:
"[They] both bring the cool project a necessary
warmth that sells their relationship, which
is the real star here."
A number of critics have noted the film's
resemblance to 2004's Eternal Sunshine of
the Spotless Mind, though this movie still
has its own unique charms. Sollosi says the
sci-fi trapping gives the film's "central
question a poetic shape," while Jordan Raup
of The Film Stage notes that:
"The details of emotional bonds are given
utmost priority in the story over extraneous
exposition related to light sci-fi touches."
In other words, if you're looking for a love
story fit for these trying times, Little Fish
might be the one for you.
Take a little romance, a little sci-fi, and
the basic premise of Groundhog Day, and you've
got The Map of Tiny Perfect Things. The plot
finds Kyle Allen as Mark, a smart teenager
stuck in a time loop, who meets Kathryn Newton's
Margaret, another teenager stuck in the same
loop. The two subsequently decide to focus
on finding the tiny, perfect things of their
endlessly repeating day.
Released on Amazon Prime Video in February
2021, The Map of Tiny Perfect Things gathered
good notices for its strong cast and its emotional
resonance. Mike Ward at Should I See It writes:
"This is a detail-driven, meticulously crafted
film that stands apart from its peers with
two strong lead performances, a bit of a mischievous
grin, and a heart firmly entrenched on its
sleeve."
Meanwhile, Shani Harris of Culturess says:
"The Map of Tiny Perfect Things is a new spin
on young love that will stimulate your mind
and touch your heart."
If you're looking for some superheroes with
your sci-fi, then Zack Snyder's Justice League
is here to save the day. This epic HBO Max
adventure, which clocks in at a mere 4 hours
and 2 minutes, may have been met with a mixed
reaction from the critics, but DC's fans couldn't
possibly be happier.
Plot-wise, the film is broadly similar to
the 2017 movie Justice League. Superman's
sacrifice in Dawn of Justice has spurred Bats
to unite a team of his superfriends to face
off against a major cosmic threat.
"I don't care how many demons he's fought
in how many hells. He's never fought us. Not
us united."
The movie has six chapters and an epilogue
for easier viewing, and characters such as
Cyborg and the Flash have their stories significantly
fleshed out, giving the film a grander scale
with deeper meaning. The Age's Jake Wilson
writes:
"This is genuinely a different film from the
earlier Justice League, and a much more coherent
one."
A running theme in the critical response to
the so-called Snyder Cut is that Zack Snyder's
strongest and weakest tendencies are both
on display. Despite agreeing that the movie
"earns its self-importance," Vulture's Bilge
Ebiri notes:
"When you get the best of Snyder, you also
get the worst."
Meanwhile, Garry McConnachie of Glasgow Live
says:
"It's big, it's brash, and it's bombastic."
So if you love DC comics and you love Zack
Snyder, you're sure as heck gonna love this.
Launching on Hulu back in March 2021, Boss
Level features a hyper-violent time loop,
a ton of action, and Frank Grillo playing
a badass former special forces agent. What
more could you possibly want?
In this case, Roy Pulver's loop involves reliving
the day on which he meets a grisly death,
forcing him to figure out who killed him — and
why — so he can end the loop and rescue
his family. In order to do so, he has to find
Mel Gibson's Colonel Ventor and avoid a whole
army of killers along the way. Grillo in particular
drew a lot of praise for his leading role
in Boss Level. Richard Roeper of the Chicago
Sun-Times compliments Grillo's ability to
carry the film, saying that:
"He pulls it off with a combination of brute
force and light charm."
Indiewire's Christian Blauvelt also gives
Grillo high marks, saying the actor gives
the film "a pulse." He continues:
"He gets you to invest in Roy enough that,
even without a controller in your hands, you
never feel like you're simply watching someone
else play a video game."
Known as Seungriho in its original Korean,
Space Sweepers takes place in a dystopian
2092. The movie follows a crew of space junk
collectors who find a robot girl named Dorothy,
who is not only wanted by the evil corporation
UTS but can also be used as a weapon. Realizing
they can make a heap of money from their discovery,
the sweepers hold her for ransom — which
turns out to be a pretty bad idea.
Space Sweepers stars Kim Tae-ri as Captain
Jang and Richard Armitage as UTS' Elon Musk-like
gazillionaire, Sullivan. South Korean writer/director
Jo Sung-Hee is the man behind the camera,
previously known for his 2012 hit A Werewolf
Boy and 2016's Phantom Detective.
Netflix released Space Sweepers in February
2021, to mostly positive reviews. Daniel Hart
at Ready Steady Cut writes:
"Space Sweepers is an energetic space adventure
that manages to slightly emotionally engage
the audience while stimulating them with fun
action sequences."
While The Stranger's Charles Mudede says:
"[Space Sweepers] features lots of explosions,
lots of robots, and that raw examination of
capitalist class structures we have come to
expect from the best of South Korea's directors."
Supposedly the last installment of Legendary's
MonsterVerse, Godzilla vs. Kong is directed
by Adam Wingard and features a host of franchise
newcomers alongside returning faces such as
Millie Bobbie Brown and Kyle Chandler.
In Godzilla vs. Kong, the gargantuan Titans
have been dormant in the three years since
Godzilla defeated King Ghidorah. Meanwhile,
the Hollow Earth theory discussed in Godzilla:
King of the Monsters has gained traction,
and the scientific agency known as Monarch
has been keeping tabs on Kong on Skull Island.
However, a mysterious force agitates Godzilla
into attacking the tech organization known
as Apex Cybernetics, and it's not long before
Kong has been co-opted into searching for
the Hollow Earth's power source. These threads
eventually converge when Godzilla's Kong-sense
kicks in, reigniting their ancient rivalry.
Upon the movie's release in March 2021, critics
praised the movie for its kaiju action, with
critic Peter Travers saying:
"The clash of these titans is spectacular
in every sense of the word."
Possibly the most glowing praise, however,
comes from Matt Zoller Seitz, who writes that:
"Godzilla vs. Kong just might be the best
studio film so far this year. If it isn't,
it's for damn sure the most fun."
As a great man once said:
"Let them fight."
An existentially fraught sci-fi drama released
on Netflix, Stowaway sends three astronauts
to Mars on a two-year mission and then throws
a major wrench into their plans when — you
guessed it — a stowaway is discovered on-board.
Director Joe Penna assembled a great cast
for this movie, which stars Toni Collette
as Marina Barnett, the ship's leader on her
final journey into space. Anna Kendrick plays
Zoe Levenson, the medical researcher, while
Daniel Dae Kim plays the ship's biologist,
David Kim. Unbeknownst to them, Shamier Anderson's
Michael Adams is also aboard, albeit unwittingly
and somehow injured. Unfortunately, whatever
caused Adams' predicament has damaged the
ship's life-support controls, leaving enough
oxygen for only three people. In his review
of Stowaway, Variety's Owen Gleiberman says:
"Penna takes a mission to Mars and unfurls
it on a direct and intimate emotional level.
We always feel the characters could be us."
Meanwhile, Christy Lemire of RogerEbert.com
writes:
"[The movie is] a clever take on a familiar
genre with a terrific cast."
If you're in the mood for a classic sci-fi
flick with a dark twist, Stowaway could be
the movie for you.
The latest movie from director Alexandre Aja,
Oxygen has been hailed as a taut, engaging
sci-fi thriller. In this Netflix French-language
film, a woman named Liz wakes up in a cryogenic
pod with amnesia, not knowing who or where
she is. Her only companion is M.I.L.O., an
artificial intelligence program, who advises
her that the oxygen levels of the pod are
decreasing at an alarming rate. If Liz can't
figure out who she is and why she's there,
she'll suffocate.
Best known for the gory horror of 2003's slasher
High Tension and 2019's alligator thriller
Crawl, Aja has been praised for his restraint
with this particular sci-fi gem. Filmed during
COVID lockdown from a 2016 script by Christie
LeBlanc, Oxygen eschews the usual viscera
for a more existential sense of dread. As
David Rooney of The Hollywood Reporter writes:
"While cult followers of Aja's extreme horror
might be let down by his turn toward more
measured sci-fi, there's plenty of creepy
unease packed into his execution of a simple
scenario that grows increasingly complicated."
Meanwhile, Brian Tallerico of RogerEbert.com
notes that:
"This truly feels like the most 'pandemic
thriller' yet in its own unpredictable way.
It's a film about isolation, loss, and an
uncertain future."
The long-awaited sequel to 2018's A Quiet
Place, A Quiet Place Part II had its theatrical-only
release in May 2021, quickly earning praise
from critics and audiences alike.
Director and screenwriter John Krasinski's
continuation of the Abbott family's story
also provides a glimpse of the first day that
the sonic aliens arrived, allowing the beloved
actor to briefly reprise his role as Lee Abbott.
Emily Blunt also returns as Evelyn Abbott,
who journeys with her newborn infant and two
older children in search of a new place to
live after their farm becomes uninhabitable.
They eventually come across Cillian Murphy's
Emmett, a once-friendly acquaintance with
links to their past. Emmett, however, is now
withdrawn and sullen, and Abbott no longer
knows if she can trust him. A Quiet Place
Part II received praise for its tight script
and superior use of tension. Matthew Rozsa
of Salon writes:
"The film is packed with visceral moments
that stick to your ribs."
Cary Darling of the Houston Chronicle also
points out that:
"[The film is] a crafty exercise in tension,
editing, and sound design that [...] never
wears out its welcome."
Bloody Disgusting's Meagan Navarro has lavished
praise on deaf actress Millicent Simmonds
in particular, saying that:
"This is above all Simmonds' show, and she
nails it."
So if you were worried about whether or not
this sequel would live up to the first film,
rest assured — it's sure to be a terrifying
treat for horror fans.
The Netflix sci-fi flick The Mitchells vs.
the Machines is a kid-friendly adventure that
hit the streaming site in April 2021. This
comedy animation follows the Mitchells, a
dysfunctional family who embark on a hectic
road trip. Unfortunately, their vacation turns
into an apocalyptic battle for survival after
the beginning of a robotic revolution. The
emphasis on technology-as-villain grounds
the film squarely in sci-fi territory as the
Mitchells, who've set aside their gadgets
for an old-fashioned vacation, are thrust
into a digital war.
The Mitchells vs. the Machines has been quite
the hit with critics, which might come as
little surprise, considering it's produced
by Phil Lord and Christopher Miller, who are
otherwise known for Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse,
The Lego Movie, and 21 Jump Street. Bob Strauss
of The San Francisco Chronicle calls the movie
"a machine apocalypse for the whole family,"
while other critics have noted the film's
surprising pro-tech stance. How's that? Well,
The Guardian's Benjamin Lee writes:
"Rather than the easier and clumsier film
[director Mike Rianda could have made, scolding
kids for swiping and tapping and missing out
on real life, he shows that young digital
creators are achieving incredible things and
that, when used right, this form of connectedness
can be a powerful force."
Free Guy stars Ryan Reynolds as the titular
Guy, a man who greets his goldfish, gets coffee,
and goes to his job at the bank. Once he's
there, he talks with his best friend, security
guard Buddy. And this is exactly what he does
every single day.
As it turns out, Guy has no idea he's stuck
in a predetermined loop as an Non-Playing
Character in a popular video game — that
is, until he meets Millie and becomes enamored.
Millie wants to prove video game impresario
Antwan stole the game she developed, so she's
looking for proof before Antwan can destroy
the game… and Guy along with it.
Directed by Shawn Levy, Free Guy received
a number of positive reviews from critics.
Charlotte O'Sullivan of The Evening Standard
praises the humor in the movie, writing:
"The humor in Free Guy is knowing rather than
nasty and, even at its most surreal, avoids
coming across as indulgent."
While Robert Daniels of The Playlist simply
writes:
"Free Guy is a winner."
Filmed on an iPhone during the COVID-19 lockdown,
the themes of the British film Infinitum:
Subject Unknown are both timely and timeless.
Written by married couple Matthew and Tori
Butler-Hart and directed by Matthew, Infinitum
stars Tori as Jane, an amnesiac woman trapped
in a parallel world — and in a time loop,
to boot. The film features cameos from Sir
Ian McKellen as Dr. Charles Marland-White
and Conleth Hill as Professor Aaron Östergaard,
both of whom may have information that could
help Jane regain her memory and return to
her own world.
In particular, Infinitum: Subject Unknown
has been praised for Tori Butler-Hart's performance.
For example, Rachael Harper at SciFiNow writes
that the actress, who's frequently alone on-screen
in the movie, "shoulders that responsibility
incredibly well," while Keri O'Shea of Warped
Perspective says:
"[Butler-Hart] pitches it perfectly given
the situations unfolding around her, and she
does most of it without saying anything."
Critics have also been impressed by how the
movie tackles its heavy and horrific themes,
with Sarah Cartland of Caution Spoilers writing
that:
"[Infinitum is] a chilling story about the
expansion of human life."
For a sci-fi flick that'll satisfy your cravings
for intensity, go no further than Infinitum: Subject Unknown.
James Gunn scores again with his take on DC
super-villains in The Suicide Squad. Less
a sequel to 2016's Suicide Squad and more
a reboot of the title, this film brings back
Harley Quinn, Amanda Waller, and a handful
of other familiar faces from the original.
At the same time, however, it brings in a
whole heap of new characters, fronted by Idris
Elba's Bloodsport and John Cena's Peacemaker.
Once again, Waller offers a ragtag group of
super-villains the chance to shave time off
their prison sentences by undertaking a secret
mission. If they go off script, however, she'll
blow off their heads. Cue the mayhem.
"We're all gonna die."
"I hope so."
The Seattle Times' Soren Andersen writes of
the film:
"Gunn masterfully mixes humor and bloodshed
and manages to give a surprising number of
characters room to develop their personas.
And when it comes to staging set pieces, he's
at his best."
While Olly Richards of Empire writes:
"When Gunn took on Guardians of the Galaxy,
he turned nonsense into gold for Marvel. By
giving The Suicide Squad the same sense of
mischief and an equally surreal streak, he's
done the same for DC."
Frank Herbert's Dune has long been considered
an unfilmable science fiction novel, but that
hasn't stopped people from trying. First there
was the 1984 David Lynch film and then the
2000 miniseries — and now its latest cinematic
incarnation has arrived. And it's pretty darn
good, too. Director Denis Villeneuve wisely
presents only a portion of Frank Herbert's
epic original novel in a way that's both satisfying
as a movie in itself and as an introduction
to the events to come.
Dune is set in 10191, a year in which House
Atreides is tasked by the Emperor to replace
the ruthless Harkonnens as overseers of the
planet Arrakis, harvesting its coveted spice
and keeping an eye on the indigenous Fremen.
The Harkonnens are less than pleased about
this, of course, and a devastating conflict
quickly erupts.
Timothée Chalamet stars as protagonist Paul
Atreides, the son of Duke Leto Atreides and
his consort, Lady Jessica Atreides. He leads
a cast that includes such stars as Zendaya,
Dave Bautista, and Jason Momoa. Audiences
and critics alike have fallen in love with
Denis Villeneuve's Dune. For example, Salon's
Melanie McFarland writes:
"It is a gorgeous sensory immersion that holds
us in its spell for hours, with an ending
that sparks yearning to see what comes next."
Meanwhile, The AV Club's Ignatiy Vishnevetsky
notes that, although the story may feel "inconclusive,":
"The resulting film is a rarity among the
overlong effects-heavy blockbusters of the
last decade: One actually wishes it didn't
have to end so soon."
In director Miguel Sapochnik's Finch, which
hit Apple TV+ in November 2021, a solar flare
has scorched the Earth, turning the planet
into a post-apocalyptic nightmare. Tom Hanks'
Finch Weinberg, a robotics engineer, has managed
to survive, along with his helper-bot, Dewey,
and dog, Goodyear. Unfortunately, Finch is
dying. To ensure his pooch's survival after
his death, Finch creates a new robot to care
for him. This robot chooses "Jeff" for its
name, but after Finch's work is interrupted,
Jeff is left with the same developmental stage
as a child. It's then up to Finch to parent
Jeff so that he can grow and care for Goodyear.
Finch is tailor-made for people who love dogs,
children, robots, and Tom Hanks. And it's
also a really gorgeous movie. Tomris Laffly
of Variety praises the movie's visuals, adding:
"Finch offers the right kind of big-budget
cinematic escape to viewers young and old,
one that's as endearingly uplifting and disarming
as a devoted good boy's unconditional company."
As you might expect, Hanks is phenomenal,
with The Austin Chronicle's Richard Whittaker
writing:
"If there is a cinematic embodiment of hope,
it may well be Tom Hanks."
As you may have heard, many of the reviews
for Marvel Studios' superhero epic, Eternals,
weren't exactly great. Sometimes, though,
you have to disregard a lousy score on Rotten
Tomatoes and go with your heart. Or in this
case, the audience score, which stands at
an impressive 80%.
Academy Award-winning director Chloé Zhao
grounds this cosmic tale of a race of immortal
beings in basic human emotions such as love
and sacrifice. The ten Eternals arrive on
Earth to defeat the Deviants, aliens who are
hell-bent on destruction. Once that's done,
the Eternals remain to observe and occasionally
assist humanity throughout history, but they're
instructed by their Celestial leader, Arishem,
not to interfere in human affairs. However,
thousands of years of observing the worst
of human behavior begins to wear on some Eternals,
and when Arishem finally reveals the Eternals'
true purpose and nature, all hell breaks loose.
It's worth bearing in mind that not all critics
slammed this film. Nina Li Coomes of the Chicago
Reader says:
"[Eternals is a] genuine, delightful character
development nestled inside of a complex and
challenging narrative."
Speaking in defense of the film, Peter Travers
of ABC News writes:
"What you'll remember is the quiet at the
heart of the storm and the intimate connections
that Zhao values above spectacle. Different?
You bet. But it's also what makes Eternals
unique and unforgettable."
Spider-Man: No Way Home earned a sparkling
slate of reviews and reached dizzying heights
in box office revenue in record time. In this
installment in the MCU, Peter Parker's identity
has been revealed to the world, forcing immense
pressure onto Parker and his friends and family.
With nowhere else to go, Parker asks Doctor
Strange for help — and inadvertently tears
open the walls of the multiverse.
"Hello Peter,"
Spider-Man: No Way Home has received especially
high marks for being a film both diehard fans
and casual filmgoers can enjoy. Cary Darling
of the Houston Chronicle wrote:
"[No Way Home is] a deft, funny and surprisingly
emotional superhero adventure that manages
to provide both fan service for the Marvel
faithful and breezy entertainment for those
who wouldn't know Peter Parker from Peter
Jackson."
Empire's Dan Jolin offered similar praise,
and added that:
"It won't just make you cheer, it'll make
you want to hug your friends, too."
In the German sci-fi romance I'm Your Man,
Maren Eggert stars as Alma, an archeologist
who agrees to participate in a unique three-week
study. The product being evaluated is a robot
named Tom, who has been programmed to be her
perfect match. Depending on Alma's verdict,
Tom and others like him could be granted human
rights. Can artificially intelligent beings
fulfill the romantic needs of someone who's
single? Should such robots have freedom? And
can Alma even begin to answer those questions?
The deep ambition that fuels I'm Your Man
has been rewarded with widespread acclaim.
Stephanie Zacharek of Time magazine says:
"I'm Your Man is funny in such a gentle way
that you may not realize how piercing it is
until after the credits have rolled."
The A.V. Club's A. A. Dowd also praised the
cast "for keeping the balance of frothy-to-thoughtful"
right where it should be. This unique film
has more on its mind than whether the girl
gets the boy, and is all the better for it.
In The Matrix Resurrections, director Lana
Wachowski returns to the dystopia of the Matrix.
Keanu Reeves is back as Thomas Anderson, this
time working as a famous game developer whose
most popular creation is a video game called
The Matrix. But Mr. Anderson keeps flashing
back to another life. While his therapist
tries to keep him grounded in "reality," it's
not long before Neo is back in the real world
and eager to search for his true love, Carrie-Anne
Moss' Trinity. Trinity believes she is Tiffany,
however, a normal mother and wife, and it's
up to Neo to free her from this new life.
The Matrix Resurrections could easily have
been a soulless cash-grab, but instead, it's
a deeply romantic and hopeful film that deconstructs
nostalgia and explores complex ideas such
as choice and purpose. Vox's Emily VanDerWerff
praised the film for its nuanced portrayal
of trauma, while Noëlle D. Lilley of The
Chicago Reader wrote:
"The Matrix Resurrections is a breath of fresh
air in a time when reboots are a dime a dozen."
Director Sion Sono's gore-soaked sensibilities
are on full display in Prisoners of the Ghostland.
Nicolas Cage gives a superb performance as
Hero, a criminal who is forced by the Governor
of Samurai Town to rescue a kidnapped girl
named Bernice from the mysterious Ghostland.
This unique movie mashes up science fiction,
western grit, dystopian drama, horror, and
samurai cinema into one completely unforgettable
experience.
While some critics found this collision of
genre a little much, others praised Prisoners
of the Ghostland for its sheer audacity. The
Independent's Clarisse Loughrey said:
"Sono may indulge in madness, but it's not
madness without reason."
Meagan Navarro of Bloody Disgusting writes:
"[Prisoners of the Ghostland] is a neon-drenched
spaghetti western full of idiosyncratic humor
and violent social messaging [...] a triumph
for bizarro cinema."
The film has also received kudos for its commitment
to an out-there storyline, while Screen Daily's
Tim Grierson praised Cage's performance as
the "high-spirited" heart of the production.
Although it's not for the faint-hearted, Prisoners
of the Ghostland is very much a thrill ride
worth taking.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.